it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what in the world it's movie
fights what's going on everybody welcome
to movie fights hashtag movie fights
live I gotta ask one question where my
house at hoot hoot hashtag all nation
Percival's in the house and I want to
give a shout-out to my friend yeah I
want to give a shout-out to my friend
Jack and his dog Grayson named after
Batman's sidekick Robin
Grayson's sick he's recovering so get
well soon Grayson hi jack all right we
got Burton fights happening today little
Tim Burton action Dumbo opening this
weekend what in the world sitting next
to me he is a former movie fights
champion the world he is our favorite
felted friend cucumber welcome back to
the party yes cucumber your Tim Burton
fan from way back right oh yeah yeah you
and I have the same eye circle problem
yeah yours are purple he has dark eye I
get that from staying up too late
sometimes
um second you know from SJ you and the
nerd goat podcast and he oh he this man
is odd he's he's the goat himself career
thank you how thank you guys I'm really
uh I'm really happy to be here I Billy
had to fill in capably for me last time
and now joe is filling in capably for
Vanessa so it's like yes it's a weird I
feel like the replacement killers yeah
oh yeah we're chou-heung fat yes and
always great to have you my friend and
last but not least he he is filling in
but he had time to come up with his own
answers today which means I'm going to
lose welcome back to the party Joestar
thank you how a redneck great to see the
Vanessa Gretton I'm thinking about your
kid and
sadly she did not provide answers so
yeah I'm gonna lose this one but it'll
be fun also how I put a toy on the table
I've heard that some of our fans really
want toys on the table
yeah I heard there was a subreddit where
everyone was saying like man this show
there's so many things wrong with it
put toys back on the table awesome Joe
thank you so much you are you're the
resident fixer you're the wolf of movies
thanks for coming in and fixing that
problem deciding today's shenanigans is
going to be myself and Dan squared it's
the Dan cam Oh Dan some people were
saying like I don't have a belt I have
to make a ding Bell I don't have to make
a ding ding noise with my mouth three of
them I know you have three of them you
know what sometimes life is just like
that Dan how's it going brother
good how are you fun facts when he said
their replacement killers I briefly got
it confused with their replacements I
was like Bobby and fat was not in that
key that would have been great and our
good friend she's like one of the best
friends of the Internet Daniel Radford
Danielle could you please tell them how
you are going to be the voice of the
people so the way that this works is
there are lots of wonderful awesome
poles that you can find online however
we have a special one here on YouTube
and that is the one that counts in case
we need a tiebreaker or just folks can't
make up their make up their mind make a
decision that's when the pole comes into
play
that's when the pole comes into play and
if you're looking on how that works go
ahead and click in the description below
bug someone in the chat we can help you
with that also please join the
discussion on hashtag movie fights live
on Twitter if I like what you're
tweeting out I might just shout you out
on the show which is great yeah I did it
throw us a couple of those dank memes
there were some stupid memes and whatnot
you know what uh felted friend yes
gentlemen are you ready to jump into the
fun yeah jump right in JT please drop
that sick ass package
ladies and gents its main event time
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks door okay question number one so
yeah Dumbo is flapping his big dumb ears
in two theaters this weekend oh yeah the
trunk full of surprises
oh boy I'm gonna clip on behind so well
this is a tough question we asked what
is the best ever Tim Burton movie damn
there's so many to choose from so many
goodies so many gems huh and we will
start off with player number one
cucumber cucumber what's the best Tim
Burton movie ever well for me the best
Tim Burton movie ever is a big fish I
think it's you know the final quote of
the film kind of wraps it up nicely as
as a masterpiece a man tells his story
so many times that he becomes the
stories they live on after him and in
that way he becomes immortal and big
fishes are strange it's beautiful film
about reconciliation with a family about
stories about lies and truth about
mistakes and because of this it is the
most moving and powerful piece of cinema
Burton ever touched because it is the
most human it is also the most
stylistically interesting of Burton's
work pushing himself to use color beauty
and whimsy and his otherwise grim and
gloomy palettes you know the falling out
of Edward and his son will the you know
that his father's Eagles as large as his
stories they all focus on himself but
you know what it's all about that
father-son relationship man and it will
stand the test of time
you know you get bored with just hey
look it's a lot of gray in people with
circles we've seen it I've seen it
and what has bonham-carter in it it's it
she's used well not just shoved in how
much I think your question answered the
question put it on pause we'll get back
to it when you jump into the fray and
what do you got
I love Q comfort can I just have that be
my answer okay huh yeah you lose you'll
slowly lose the round oh okay he's a
he's my man can jumping you right now oh
yeah Billy Hoyle
all right basically my pick for the
greatest Tim Burton and best Tim Burton
movie is the one I feel where he's
operating at the absolute height of his
powers and he's doing his his his his
ouvre the best he can and he also has
willing and able collaborators to help
him to steer the ship and that movie is
Batman 1989 Batman it is people credit
blade blade is a really great movie and
it was the precursor for this era but
guess what if there's never a Batman 89
that comes out and causes such a stir
and become such a national phenomenon we
never I don't think maybe this years
later that we might accept actual
superhero movies play was a genre movie
with superhero elements Batman is a
straight-up superhero movie that America
accepted on the grandest scale possible
it was at one time the largest grossing
movie ever and it was because of Tim
Burton's direction and playfulness with
it had just enough whimsy for people who
thought comic books were a joke but just
enough dark stuff to get people really
and drawled in the story and that that
delicate dance I think it's the one time
he really played that delicate dance
perfectly
it's Batman 89 that delicate bat dance
Joestar yes Adam West I went with a
different movie than the two of these
gentlemen I was good that was a weird
thing to say I went with Batman Returns
yes Batman 89 is a great movie and big
fish is is a lovely movie but I think
Batman Returns is is definitely the best
of these three it's it's a better movie
it's a better Tim Burton movie and I
think it's a better Batman movie than
Batman 89 I think this is Tim Burton
really getting comfortable with like the
Tim Burton enos of his take on Batman
the the it's it's this Burton thing has
everything it's got weird sex stuff it's
got weird dead trees it's got a weird
rich villain it delves into weird dad
issues just like big fish does the
relationship with father and son and
weird estranged identities and and and
all of that it
really just cut out clowns clowns galore
you guys the red triangle gang are much
scarier clowns than Jack Nicholson's
Joker and you got to have scary clowns
if you're gonna do a Burton thing
there's weird mouth stuff it has all the
Burton elements it's a it's it's a
stronger Burton movie it's a better
Batman movie than then 89 yeah Batman
Returns let's shout about it
alright shout about it fight about it
the question is what is the best movie
of the bunch not what is the best comic
book movie or what is the best Batman
movie is what's the best Tim Burton
movie and I think for me what makes the
best movie is how is it effective how
does it how does it move you how does it
make you feel and think and I think even
even production quality wise or the
effects in production design and big
fish we're gorgeous especially when
taking into account the dual realities
of Edwards stories and the reality once
things are revealed and the most drawing
and effective of those are the final
scene with the with the you know when
everyone comes to to bid him farewell
well the fantasy version and then the
actual funeral rate later when you
realize everything was true this is how
I go it's freaking moving it's beautiful
as opposed to you want to get max let's
get not chuckle about that for a couple
of days but it's not it's not the
greatest for a couple of decades
cucumber I don't know how old you are
I don't know how friends give it away a
little bit but maybe that's just stress
all I'm saying doesn't do hair when
these arms are trackless all I'm saying
is that we're talking about Tim Burton's
Tim Burton's he's almost a genre unto
himself and we think of him as that
because when when he applied his vision
to something as simplistic and the minds
of the people at the time as Batman I
mean we're dealing with a time when when
Paramount wouldn't make a Batman because
they had already made Robin and Maid
Marian and they didn't think Batman and
Robin would sell we're talking about a
time when people were talking about
Batman in space as a TV movie for CBS
and and Tim Burton takes that with with
the help of Sam Hamm
and makes a screenplay that everybody
can can identify with and enjoy as a new
type of genre movie and that's why it
was such a phenomenon and is quite much
more phenomenon than either these movies
this movie sank him as being part of
that and he shot he did shoot his his
wad of like unchecked ridiculousness
onto your movie that's absolutely true
but he was reined in on mine and that's
why it's better I would I would argue
that that reining him in on Batman 89
detracted from the film in a lot of ways
more playing ball with Warner Brothers
whereas I think if as a director if your
Eid is I myself am strange and unusual
and you're not able to fully realize
that vision I think that's a detraction
whereas with Batman Returns he just dove
right in to the point that like
McDonald's was like yeah no more toys on
this weird Bert and stuff and I I think
I'll take sort of that strong director
vision over just sort of mainstream
successful comic book movie any day I
think the characters and Batman Returns
are much more fully realized Michael
Keaton's able to settle in more with the
performances Bruce Wayne I won't go I
won't go I won't jump off the ledge of
Michelle Pfeiffer's performances
Catwoman is better than Heath Ledger's
performance as the Joker but I think if
there is any performance that you can
say who who is the best comic book movie
villain performance the conversation
next to ledger has to be Michelle
Pfeiffer and I would just like that I
would just like to rebut the fact that
you said there's more there are more
characters I don't know that they're
more developed and just getting to big
fish so we don't neglect cucumber and in
this particular path of destruction I
feel as though big fish is him going so
much against his instincts that it shows
glaringly and how bright and sunny some
of it was and how he was almost trying
to trying to it was almost like R&B
artists trying to do a country song just
to kind of throw everybody off and it
changed something you know I mean and I
feel like that was a little a little
force and I feel like when we go back
through his entire filmography we'll see
Batman as a Titan and we'll see big fish
as an amusement mmm all right let's go
into our final thoughts cucumber lay it
on us
I think that I disagree with that last
one I think that II he hits all of his
major artistic points in big fish
without having to drown you in them he
doesn't beat you over the head with like
the spooky circus looking stuff but it's
still there and he still managed to tell
a very personal and very deeply moving
story with fully fleshed out characters
with actual relationships it's not a not
a broad strokes cartoon even though some
of the man's tall tales are the the
story at the heart of it is is solid and
true and he did it in such a beautiful
way I think some of us can work is that
is the best way I've ever seen iPad I
think he nailed it with a big fish
thanks cucumber and final thoughts my
final thoughts are the fact that like I
think we're trying to poopoo Tim and Tim
Burton on some level by even me saying
that it was too far in Batman but I read
men Returns and that it's too little in
this but I feel like if we're gonna look
at it that way and see that spooky
circus and creepy pale guy lust after a
blonde girl that he gets in the end if
we're gonna say that that's his genre
which it is Batman is the movie that
does that and he serves the corporate
masters in a way that is quite beautiful
and artistic even down to certain fight
choreography and stuff that the ballet
of how even the the stiff Keaton food
that he was doing in there was beautiful
and and and the design of the Batmobile
got them as a real place not just as
Nolan does a redress Pittsburgh you
don't I mean I feel like Gotham is a
real place and so all of these things
are key to Burton things and we're
talking about
oh he's drowning in greatness and
drowning in black because this movie was
so successful he got to do it 15 more
times he got to do it 15 more times
because of this movie not Beetlejuice
not something else this movie allowed
him to have the cart want to do whatever
he wanted in his weird style forever and
that is why it is a truly Titanic
achievement and the best Tim Burton
movie Thank You Joestar I agreed with it
I'll agree with that sort of in the
swimming in the black sand weirds I
think that's where that that sort of
gothic angle is really where Tim Burton
thrives and while there are definitely
elements of the Gothic South in big fish
I think there
full sort of display in Batman Returns
just in terms of pure camera work and
setting up scenes you know his entrance
into the chaos as the red triangle gang
crashes master X Christmas tree lighting
is just is just wonderful reestablishing
the characters he just moves through and
just takes out all these just weird
bizarre goons the the sequence of Selina
Kyle returning home the hell here is is
masterful it's a beautiful sequence it's
an absolutely beautiful piece of
filmmaking the very melancholic ending
where Bruce Wayne finally feels like
he's connected with someone straight
from the moment of does this mean we
have to start fighting because of the
mistletoe callback which is great riding
all the way down to four or five still
alive counting down the last of her
lives because she's chosen revenge on
Max Schreck over being with Bruce Wayne
like just messes with so many of those
themes that Burton loves about romance
and commitment and the threat of
commitment on to that last sort of sad
scene of goodwill towards men and women
from from Michael Keaton which was just
really really brilliantly delivered
right it's just on this beautiful somber
sad note right before the elements core
just like cranks in I think it's it's
Burton at the height of his powers for
for lack of a better phrase mr. Rudnick
and yeah Batman Returns time there it is
alright Burton round in the books now as
always left is the facts and the judging
Dan Moreau what's going on the facts so
what the fact that I did have to point
out which is that Batman 89 was not ever
with the highest-grossing film of all
time
et held that record until Jurassic Park
took it over in 1993 so it was certainly
very successful but it was not the
highest grossing of all time gotcha
thank you always get trouble out roses
how do I get sidetracked where's gone
with the wind like factored into that
with adjusted well when you adjust to
this number one it's made like like over
a billion domestic if you adjust for
inflation then you can get Gone with the
Wind there's an holy schnike yes alright
Dan any other facts or no facts know
that that's my factual
Yeah right on um so uh yeah this this
was a a difficult round of judge because
you uh you all had different arguments
that really lent credence to your
choices but at the end of the day I
thought Edie you we loomed a little too
much into how Batman changed the
superhero genre and not how it was Tim
Burton's best film and I feel like it
didn't hear enough of that to go there
even though your points are spot-on
about how it opened the door and we
wouldn't have so much of the good stuff
we have today without Batman 89 so it
came down to Joe and cucumber for me and
I was you know what it was it's it's
cucumber until they they hit him with
just it being a departure from his
normal over so much so that it's it's
kind of like glaring that it's so off
track from what he usually does and that
really got me thinking oh yeah that
resonated I don't feel like we had any
come back from that and Joe hit a lot of
great points that Selena Kyle Michelle
Pfeiffer Catwoman the Tim Burton playing
like just full-out and all of the
elements in that movie I thought at the
end of the day Joe and his final
thoughts won me over song going Joe star
Dan yeah I mean I hear you but for me I
I see where they're coming from with
that argument against big fish but for
me it's it's I was interpreting it's not
most Tim Burton movie it's still best
timber yes
and so even given that and you know Joe
so made a very specific final argument
but I felt that was more of just a recap
of moments in the film
whereas I found Keuka I think cucumber
is Leonard Maltin in disguise because
that breaks down the big fish to open I
thought was great yes I felt like we got
into so many intricacies of Batman and
bad verse and this is the great for the
superhero genre I think you come from
made a great argument about why it why
big fish is a great film you know
wit including tim burton's style and not
including it so I I cited with cucumber
I I he made the argument for me right on
Danielle can you uh can you help us out
here alright let's see what the polls
say and wait 38% for big fish really
said for Batman Returns and 24% for
Batman a couple of things I saw first of
all II D mentioning that it's like
someone in our and be doing country and
not getting it right I think that
Beyonce's daddy lessons would like a
word with you I've been holding that in
for several minutes and also one-quarter
Canadian on Twitter drink responsibly
she has come up or they have come up
with a movie fights live drinking game
oh yeah don't you suppose to use water
vitamins or weed if you are in a state
where it's legal yes very cool Thank You
Danielle I would be remiss if I did not
say you know what I'm not supposed to
chime in with my own opinions here but
pee-wee's big adventure Beetlejuice
Edward Scissorhands and what all bears
and also
big fish is best movie yeah I'd say big
fish or ed would but I didn't feel like
I could get as much dust out fun I also
want to argue Sleepy Hollow but I really
like talking about oh my god oh my god
okay uh alright sorry I had to get that
off my chest by the way if you liked if
you like this round please go ahead and
like and subscribe by the way to screen
junkies and SJ news and everything
screen junkies related please like and
subscribe I thank you and cucumbers up
1-zip let's move to question numero dos
I'm proud of the audience for voting for
the cool movie and not just the
superhero stuff done yes
alright here's question number two a New
Jersey high school stage production of
alien went viral this week Jersey
represent what movie would make the
absolute best possible high school play
reminds me a little bit of Rushmore and
some of the stage productions there um
what movie would make the absolute best
high school play
question number two we'll start with
player number two mister ed Grier well I
picked jaws and I think it is an
ambitious stage play to try it for four
for high schoolers to try to do but I
think it's doable especially with a
certain certain little alterations and
there's a lot of if you think about it
there's a lot of times when you're doing
a play a lot of kids are just sort of
standing around smoking cigarettes
making fun of the kids who get to act
because there's not too much you know
stuff going on there's all kind of props
and set changes and stuff going on the
waves for the initial attack scene and
the little rig where we're gonna jerk
the young lady around and stuff as she's
being attacked and the plumes of uh you
know cucumber could probably help me
with some of the stage plumes of that
gems of red you know a red yarn or
whatever flying up in the sky you know
mean so get that and then like I was in
the water the seams are the scenes on
Brody and Hooper kind of opened the
shark because they know the Kitner boy
is not in there and they're like finding
like a license plate a rocking chair and
iPhone 5 you know we got to update it
you know for the kids you don't I mean
and and I just feel like you know that
the whole I will drink to your I'll
drink to your legged Rictor like three
kids doing that three get a kid doing
quints speech about the Annapolis and I
went down and all of those people got
ate and eaten by sharks a little kid
going you know me oh my god I just I'll
save some of the rest for the other but
it's come on man Josh as a stage play
with high schoolers it's really cool all
right thank you
Edie Joe how I am myself a survivor of
high school drama programs hmm sadly
that abuse continued into a high school
theater or a college theater major and
coming out of the other side of all of
that you have to ask yourself what do
you want out of a high school play
because they're never going to be good
let me use an end strategy here let me
redefine the question what I want what I
consider a best high school play is how
much entertainment value am I going to
get out of this how how memorable are
these terrible weird performance is
going to be what weird stuffed at the
high school what weird changes that the
high school have to make to the play so
that they could even do it and for that
reason I'm picking pulp fiction for the
Centauri I just want to see you a bunch
of high school okay
one of my friends in the Bible Belt did
grease and they changed her having a
getting pregnant and having a baby to
her having cancer because the school
didn't want to talk about high school
and I can only imagine what a Bible
about high school wood pulp fiction -
the [ __ ] suit - do I look like a [ __ ]
one to say what one more mother effing
time - turning the the actual Bible
verse monologue into into an actual
well-meaning parts about by about Bible
verses maybe I don't know too
downplaying the violence
I just think that this would be a
brilliant beautiful disaster the parents
and the audience would be uncomfortable
the drama teacher who thought this would
be really cool and hip would immediately
be fired
it would just be at an incredible
beautiful disaster as all proper high
school drama should be alright the
beautiful disaster of Pulp Fiction
cucumber what you got I've got Pan's
Labyrinth because they're things as
engaging as a well-constructed parable
wearing a fairy tale suit it's a high
school production of Pan's Labyrinth it
could engage classes of varying subjects
and students of varying interests as
Beauty violence elegance magic history
philosophy themes of rebellion it's all
rolled into one
and they could even have two versions of
the play on different nights one in
Spanish for your Spanish classes and one
in English bloody deaths mask mask work
and puppetry opportunities to keep their
hearts happy there's also brilliant and
powerful scenes that the theatre kids
would just eat up there's there are so
many like great deaths and interrogation
scenes like more than one in that in
that story that these kids would just
eat up everyone has a really really cool
part and the theater kids as they're
rewriting the script they can learn
about speech acts and the power of words
and story because every statement in
that movie matters and it's great and
then like the finds reality of the story
it's super super fun from the show as
your heavy breathing says do you want us
to open it up now or it's going one more
thing yes make a lot about Francoist
Spain from this show so you can even
apply it to history and Spanish classes
mmm all right fight it out y'all I just
you know what I think you guys have
pitched two beautiful disasters well I
have pitched something that will
actually go viral in the same way that
this alien production would from from
the production design look kids building
the Orca they'd have to have a shark
team a team of big kids inside the show
I'm sorry acting out the shark parts
you'd have you have so many
opportunities for kids that have cool
parts I'd have I'd expand maybe mrs.
Brody's role however have a few more
scenes you can only play the there are
no small parts only small actors
to a bunch of high school kids that
desperately want to be famous so many
times and sharp number four and sharp
number five and sharp number six and
sharp number seven are just not going to
have it that's important you simply
don't have a large enough cast most kids
don't like acting and the 15th time I
hear oh hey when he goes to Indochina I
want to I want a ninja hiding in a bowl
of rice the 15th time I hear that it's
not funny anymore you know there's a lot
of that so I and also I just think it's
it's got a bunch of sets mine can be
truncated better than either of these I
think into a 1 to 3 set is the
transition that's part of taking you
there that's two kids behind a cardboard
cutout of a car while they discuss a
Royale with cheese that passes in front
of a diner set one that's a beautiful
high school student transition that is a
set that parents are going to want to
come in on the weekend and help paint I
just can't wait to see this show
Hamilton it is an issue you have pitched
an educational nightmare for especially
the kids aren't that good at Spanish but
they're in that cool Spanish class and
they gotta watch it in Spanish and in
English
you've made an arduous task for kids
whereas I feel as though and so as you
know and as everybody here knows when
you were in theater as a kid 90% of the
kids any want to be there so yes they
get to do something fun with a shark to
get the build stuff to get all the
robotics dorks get to help with the jaws
you don't have a door with the gimbal
that that that that tells the Orca the
barrel boy's humor RC
we've got the barrel boys the barrel
boys represent the strike what you can't
see the Sharks club is gonna play ball
with coach Carmody who has been just
groped into directing this high school
play I don't think so you're putting in
too many elements of clubs there's too
many pilots Dixon high school to pull
off your play and whereas with pulp
fiction you're getting a little bit as
foreign language education because
there's a little bit of French okay it's
a multicast you know some great great
fantastic monologues scene-stealing
moments some fun weird special effects a
guy accidentally shot in the head and
some kid gets to just wing a bottle of
heinz ketchup against a window I think
it's gonna be really great it's also
told out of order so if kids start to
forget their lines and screw up it's
fine you just switch to another sign to
get it go this is this this dream you're
selling it's not gonna get past the
table read the zero way at least
cucumber is putting up a very boring
thing think kids would like and and I'm
doing an old movie so at least we're
battling out something actually happen
with a bottle in this movie they break
fingers with pliers this is not this
gentle boring solid that would be
neutered in the production where is my
shot we did Scarface but we come from we
had different schools I think most of
the schools in America
right now could deal with the fantasy
violence of my shark could deal with the
fact that all the kids have to
participate to make this hurt this is
the final thought yeah deal with the
fact that all the kids will be able to
participate in this production and
there's mud there's a bunch of parts the
mayor I look in with a gray wig doing
the mayor who
close the beach oh my god a sophomore
smacking chief Brody's glasses off
because her Kitner boy is dead come on
man
that's nuts and there's beach scenes
there's water scenes there's action
there's adventure and there's a bunch of
parts where a young Olivier the one guy
was gonna make it at the Dustin Hoffman
of school gets to play Quint and he just
kills it so there's all of these things
I do believe contribute to an actual
viral play they could actually be and I
think that's what separates mine from
some of these other ones that this the
last thing I think yours would be a
little boring and educational I think
they would get into the fantasy and the
fun of doing mine thank you Adam by the
way Olivier and Dustin Hoffman appeared
together in Marathon Man juster how I
think one of the biggest problems with
this jaws play is one of the things that
makes jaws the movie work is the the few
times that you see the shark you don't
you don't see it often so I think with
this Jaws play you're gonna see a lot of
kids sitting on boats looking out into
the middle distance reciting lines
talking about a visceral experience of
that that we ourselves necessarily don't
get to to experiences audience members
watching the play that we would get if
we were watching the film it's also very
reliant on the John Williams score to
sort of queue up tension and and stuff
like that
whereas pulp fiction this high school
production there's plenty of just weird
characters for kids to play the
neutering of it will only improve and
enhance it because people will be like I
can't wait to see how they do any of
this with a bunch of children and just
at a personal story when I would I was
in college I had did a lot of sound
design for theater and I went into sound
design for a high school production of
Beauty and the Beast and during one of
the beasts songs his mic stopped working
I ran backstage and he was just this
sobbing like high school football player
who his parents came to see him that
night and this was his big night to make
his dad understand that he just wanted
to sing and so imagine that moment if
you will and just consoling this child
that really wants to convince his dad
that he wants to be an entertainer and
not a quarterback and then he puts on
the gimps
back on stage but that's a that's a
beautiful moment to me how and I can't
wait to direct it someday
alright Joestar oh I guess applying for
a high school theater teacher job can
make youtube videos forever how all
right bring out the [ __ ] cucumber best
possible high school play yours as yours
has this whole like the this it all
entirely runs on the fact that it is
neutered and edited down to being
unrecognizable to me that is not a
success for the translation of this show
as for Jaws I kind of agree the the
shark will never show up it's just gonna
be a bunch of kids squinting in the
invisible sunlight and coughing or
something like I don't even know but I
think Pan's Labyrinth you have you have
smaller stories within the larger
stories that can even break it up which
is something that Shakespeare doesn't do
you know this is one big long yeah I'm
right this way you get your little fairy
tales and you get the thing with the
Frog you thing with a pail man you get
all this and stuff it's broken up and
it's interesting it's also visually
interesting cuz each monsters is
distinct and different and beautiful it
will move differently they can see
little kids on stilts don't talk about
cool costumes and a kid on the cool
little life like big stilts like
wobbling around you have like your
little rock star playing princess
mallanna Oh feel yeah you can even get
the choir involved to sing the lullaby
oh it would be so pretty but it's so
good and heaven forbid it'd be
educational and if they and something
strikes the hearts true of these young
folk so many beautiful elements that's
all I'm saying
alright time there you have it I didn't
bring you under the show to keep
embarrassing us
dan take us on a trip to the fact zone
and then give us your thoughts on this
argument back zone first quite was on
the USS Indianapolis at the Annapolis
she's the only one of the most famous
speeches in movie history
another line another line correction
it's not say what one more GD time it
I'm sorry it's not say what one more
mother effing time it's I dare you I
double dare you mother effer
say what one more GD time into the the
samuel l.jackson line must be sanitized
so that's not delivered by a 15 year old
boy and and that was my issue with well
listen okay i'm hashtag triggered by
this round because i did drama tech in
high school we all wanted to be there
we built the sets we painted everything
ourselves it wasn't coached by high
school coach we all had fun the shows I
don't think we're terrible we did have
us we did have a performance of grease
for elementary school students where he
had to change the plot so that Rizzo got
dumped by Kenickie instead of knocked up
by Kenickie but we can do the regular
version at night so I take umbrage with
this depiction of high school theater
that's powerless kids
propped up by adults who don't want to
be there because we have a damn good
time we did good work not impressed by
the sweat on stage and off stage right
here as a chorus member as a chorus
member in South Pacific body marry girl
I will say it falls somewhere in between
all right okay even putting that aside
[Music]
even putting that aside I couldn't go
with Jose because I agree the whole
thing was based on a contempt for the
art form and just to be what I would
want to see so it was between edy and
cucumber and this was back and forth the
whole time for me but I think it is
closing cucumber conditionally like this
is a school play it's a it's it's a
night it's a chance for it to agree
what's so wrong with being educational I
love the multi lingual aspect of it you
could do performances in different
languages you could I love bringing in
the orchestra and the different people
from the school so I'm going with
cucumber and Pan's Labyrinth I came down
to ed and cucumber for me as well for
the same reason you said Joe pick
something fun but it was just like let's
see
like you like presented a variable into
the mix like how weird is it and not the
thing is it going to be which is one
world of chaos yeah but yeah why hair
the one who got me most excited for for
their production was Ed Greer I just the
blood in the water the Quint monologue I
mean those are my two favorite things I
want to see from this round and they
both were from Ed's argument so I'm
going ed Danielle what do we got
confusion hell yes at 42% the chat wants
to see the world burn with pulp fiction
4% for Pan's Labyrinth
23% for jaws so that means it's me
yep it's my job you're gonna break that
time I'm gonna break that tie and I got
to cosign what other Dan said I do want
to see a train wreck I do want to see
them see kids try to figure out how to
be a shark but at the end of the day I
think that cucumber came he sir you have
come to with
you are correct for this fight and so
yeah I got to give this to cucumber
cucumber takes the point see you can do
for you guys before play ever again
cucumber off to a 200 lead were there
any other good answers that you really
dug Danielle um the checks like Joe I'm
not gonna repeat some of these names
yeah one of them was a film and
Szczerbiak don't look it up
check out real nihilistic yeah yeah Chad
will do that sometimes
alright so this Joe and Ed are looking
to get on the board cucumber look at
nice and dicey now cucumber looking to
pitch a shutout here alright here is
question number three the future of the
Transformers franchise is currently in
doubt in the spirit of Hailee Steinfeld
and bumblebee pitch your actor
transformer duo movie alright
pitch your actor and transformer duo
movie will start with player number
three Joe star so we've done a bunch of
things over and over again with the
Transformers we've introduced them to
earth for the first time multiple times
now we've we've watched and punched a
bunch of Decepticons multiple times of
so I think we need to do something
different so what I'm sort of
envisioning is we're well into the
future
wars over everyone we've almost sort of
entered more of a cold war everyone sort
of trying to figure out peace Cybertron
and other weird alien planets earth
stuff like that and my duo is Charlize
Theron and one of my favorite Autobots
prowl
I love Charlize Theron in atomic blonde
I think she's so cool as like a badass
spy just like working on the front lines
trying to collect information trying to
outwit other spies and prale is this
really awesome character who just lives
in moral grace he is full-on for the
greater good he would stab Optimus Prime
in the back if he honestly believed that
that is what would lead to ever
lasting peace there's a great storyline
in the comics where this technology this
computer gets discovered that measures
guilt and he knows that if like Autobots
ever get hooked up to it people are
going to actually see them for the
actual like criminals of war that they
probably are and goes to great dark
lengths to conceal that from the public
so that it remains a win for the
Autobots so I love the idea of the two
of these people being paired up in in
service of one common goal but they're
constantly you know like a spy versus
spy situation but with a very cool
blonde lady and a robot that turns into
a police car you know one up and each
other stabbing each other in the back
twist double twist I'm I just think that
that would be really really cool it
gives you the opportunity to tell it
just like Marvel sort of having to
figure out doing now like okay yeah it's
a comic book movie but is it a fun space
adventure is it a cool espionage movie I
think now we're getting to the point
where we need to do the same thing with
the Transformers movies like yeah it's a
transformers but like what kind of movie
is it is it you know is it a romantic
comedy is it a cool spy movie I think
this gives you a cool genre opportunity
yeah jost are giving a genre twist is
choice thank you Joe cucumber back or
any of alright so mines kind of like a
mix between an eight-mile and karate
kick what in the world I want to mix up
Donald Glover and Soundwave so get a
whole album done by you know childish
gambino would be super super sweet but
the main idea the story is after failing
what could have been on a life changing
songwriting competition after his
dangerous rival destroyed his equipment
to leave its tracks yadda yadda sabotage
this musician stuck working in a
junkyard so he finds a micro cassette
player and in a moment of inspiration he
starts recording some lyrics and that's
when Soundwave comes back online but he
does have his memory so as he's booting
up sup whop whop whop jimbob's yep right
and then one word comes out in its
superior and so he bases his next
kick-ass song off of the word superior
which is so then a sound wave kind of
you know he's still got his same
attitude but doesn't really know where
his alliances lies so he partners up
with this donald glover human and they
go through like up the ranks of like
underground music
doing these things he poses as as like
his sound system at all the gigs and
he's got you know ravaged Laserbeak
buzzsaw Ratbat Rumble frenzy slugfest
and overkill they're kind of like the
entourage keeping him safe from the
opponents the rival kids we're going in
there to like you know mess stuff up or
whatever so now it's like they can't
destroy his equipment cuz his equipment
fights back so he actually gets election
as an artist and do all this really cool
stuff but at the head but halfway
through the movie megatron finds his
lieutenant Soundwave and wants to bring
him back into the fold so what does he
do is he gonna is he is he gonna is he
gonna finish the concert and help his
friend or he's gonna go back and destroy
the Autobots what's he gonna do guys
damn you left us on a cliffhanger
cucumber you all right edy what do you
got all right I've got to give it all I
got in this one guys this is this is
this is a this is Optimus Prime
driving up that hill saying you got the
touch oh you got to touch his plan and
I'm gonna shoot you guys while I'm doing
flips this movie is the best one of
these and it is Transformers survivors
starring the rock and Optimus Prime we
are in a far-flung war turn war-torn
earth where there are very small pockets
of humanity that still manage to live in
small fiefdoms that are technologically
deprived and stuff and there are a
couple of great nights like like Optimus
Prime that are still here but they're in
raggedy States they're you know they're
in like hiding like the Jedi after the
giant war the Sith war and basically
what it is is Optimus Prime gets the
matrix stripped from him by a group of
feral robots from the outer reaches of
space the fear of the transformers we
forgot about the horrible forgotten ones
who are on penal colonies and stuff and
these guys come back and they they have
kaiju forms because all they've seen are
crazy aliens of last millennia so they
change into horrific animal forms as
their transformation thing and then of
course their humanoid forms are horrific
as well and they make these gangs that
basically basically run the earth right
now and one of these gangs traps down
Optus prime rips the matrix from his
chest because what they're going to do
is give the matrix to their giant mecha
let's sort of Lord that's coming down
and once he gets the matrix all is lost
and there'll be nothing to stop them and
basically so with the matrix ripped out
barely clean their life he crawls a
hundred miles to the rocks house and has
his old friend from the tear from the
last days of the TRF that the humans who
help the Transformers in the great Wars
the last one alive the one who and both
of them have intense survivor's guilt
because they've all survived longer than
all of their soldiers so these two older
men at this point you know would bring
up the rock a little bit he's almost 50
now anyway
it's sort of old man Logan starring
Optimus Prime and the rock trying to
rediscover a sort of Unforgiven esque
lethality that they used to have in
their youth combined with the survivors
are more so about living their soldiers
and they combine as a force to set
things right fight it out
oh and using that old movie fight slogan
shortcut that's part of the drinking
game a bit the Donald Glover Soundwave
thing I think that the character on one
hand I was like what this work better
with blaster but then when you describe
the the plot I was like oh that was the
plot of bumblebee basically if you use
the Autobot I think with the hook with
with with it with the cliffhanger the
the the thing that defines Soundwave
more so than the tapes and the voice is
just unwavering cold loyalty so the
moment his memories back he just mercs
everyone in the vicinity and and the
credits rolling that's a weird and
loyalty that Donald Glover so he has
conflicting look guys I don't want to
pile on because I want to see step up to
the robots or Decepticons to EMP
Boogaloo or whatever I I'd love to see
that on some level but again I am not
joking around I'm not joking around did
you lose this round to play
oh no and not to make friends either
I just feel as though mine is a
real-deal movie because the rock as a
real scarred William money from
Unforgiven type figure who's drawn back
into this transformer crap I'm on my
Mountain hilltop him like God I'm like
honest wasn't going commando maybe he's
got a daughter saw these carrion trees
he's just kick it in and he's can pull
there you pulled me back into the
Cybertronian crap and it's an it's a new
threat we haven't seen before these
super duper transformers that are coming
down with their new king that are gonna
go to the matrix that's gotta be cool
and the rock I saved this for last the
rock is going to the rock and Optimus on
there they have to do a Lord of the
Rings type quest to even get to where
they're gonna get the matrix back from
the big robot and what they do on that
quest is fine to construct the cons and
the Dinobots make a super giant mega
kaiju fighting robot to fight this mega
Godzilla's come from space and the rock
drives that well Optimus Prime is
fighting other robots is your kingdom a
bigger threat than other robots no but
if you're continuing like the smaller
scope of like hey we're focusing on like
a person and and and a robot I think you
have or you have you can focus you can
do a character-driven movie with a
larger scope threat in mind was sort of
is the espionage movie how who's the
other side say an espionage there are
two sides we have SP and I was going on
with the Russians there are one side we
are one side who are the sides the
Decepticons are side the Autobots are
side Earth's aside one side as Charlize
Theron on that's okay Brow's on his own
side slash the greater good side don't
know if I need to see another movie with
the rock and a giant CG sidekick this is
completely fair yeah I have seen rampage
once that that's a very good point those
things just work yeah
it's all about the wasted supporting
cast in cucumbers because you want to do
sort of this this hip-hop
eight-mile situation but you know
Soundwave you know maybe good for beats
but just in terms of pure lyrical
delivery is going to get old after a
while
Laserbeak and ravage are not linguistic
Rumble and frenzy I think are too dumb
to like put intelligent rhymes together
to help Donald lever one fest is an
idiot and overkill also doesn't speak
that well so you're not really like
aiding donald glover beyond like
Soundwave can make cool beats sound wise
Soundwave ejects them to go and spy on
the other bands and so there will be a
conflict where he accidentally steals a
song because he thinks they're feeding
him good music cuz all they care about
is winning they don't care how they do
it you officially got to the trifecta I
said a break in step with the streets
and now you've got bring it on there you
go final thoughts Joestar give us your
final summation I think there's
something cool about playing with the
larger world of these characters what
actually makes them tick getting beyond
sort of the michaelbay like just like
smashing action figures together like
what are the rules of this world what
are the politics what are the what are
the Alliance is moving back and forth
and if you set that against something
sort of like a you know for lack of a
better word like an intergalactic Berlin
wall or something like that with these
two people who are supposed to be
working together but with their own
personal agendas I think that gives you
a a really cool compelling human
character doesn't just feel like they're
tacked on to the robot story because the
producer was like there has to be a
person in this and it gives you a really
cool compelling deep thought-out
character in prowl going well above and
beyond any of the character work in the
Michael Bay movies well above and beyond
the character work in bumblebee because
beyond being like adorable we didn't get
a whole lot of what makes bumblebee tick
but I think here you have a really cool
suspense character piece with these two
characters thank said character so many
times that's okay I put a toilet yeah
there's
you have the toy Thank You Joestar back
around the cucumber final thoughts I
mean I think this really mine is really
in the vein of you know Hailee Steinfeld
a bubbly it's just we pair up these two
characters and again he's a villain and
eventually he'll remember it's which
which adds to the story later all of his
little ejector many-many transformers
will have their own jobs and everything
but it's like they they mess up as much
as they as much as they help because
they don't know how to help with
conscience so you have to deal with that
as well so like how does how does he
bounce back from that now realizing oh
man I cheated I made it this far by
cheating so and I actually really got to
write my one good son and he's got to do
it but I think like a day in the life
sort of of movie with transformers as
opposed to the same thing with giant
explosions and all supper like over
there little space and find the thing
before the thing blows up I like the
idea of exploring these these characters
and situations that they normally would
not be in so putting Soundwave in a
place where he's confused and has to
kind of be a good guy but doesn't know
how I think a little more interesting
than all these people playing their
regular notes cucumber I thank you edie
what do you got look guys there's a
reason why people like the end of things
there's a reason why people like the
last ride type of movies the Wild Bunch
and the N and Butch Cassidy the Sundance
Kid wild hogs there's a reason why
people like that sort of stuff because
when you look at a conflict like this it
is normally some human some robots
having some sort of dispute and and
mostly it's just the humans are some
sort of Fallout and this I feel like the
ending I'm pitching or I'm envisioning
in my movie is after this big crummy
battle takes places but which is gonna
be the last of the transformer battles
the matrix would it would be donated to
humanity as a power source for us to
come back out of the dark ages in in a
way
Optimus is very big fan of sacrificing
ourselves I feel like these movies are
about too much war and not enough about
the fact that some wars are fought for a
peace right so I feel like at the end of
this movie there would actually be a
sort of peace and we could do other
transformer stories but they wouldn't
have to be so Optimus centric because he
made his final big sacrifice ain't did a
big thing and I just really feel as
though my movie has two characters we're
gonna say character a billion times that
again the survivors are more about
living all your soldiers the
outliving your usefulness on this earth
as a warrior and finding that back and a
grand battle at the end when you pull it
pull it up for one last time
I just feel like that's a lot more
moving than a vaguely Illustrated
espionage movie or sort of you know
bring it on with the robots and jazz and
I feel like a demo Glover would end up
being just sort of a pawn and the game
in that movie whereas I feel like
Optimus Prime and the rock are true-blue
partners the last of their kind uniting
for one last ride I feel like that's
more moving than both of both of my
opponents find contributions to this
argument thank you for your fine
contribution ding ding that's our round
three Dan please take us to the fact
zone oh thank you compassionate I mean
let's let's be honest here Joe could
have made up most of what he said about
the Transformers and I couldn't have
told you the difference
Oh slug fest is an idiot I didn't make
that up very hard arrows to that round
it was an ideas round though I will say
that Dwayne Johnson will be 47 years old
on May 2nd uh-huh that's about all I can
add fact okay so that argument thank you
thank you thank you Dan
great so the s3 interesting films I
thought they each of these films had
their had their own individual merits
and and really cool fun stuff Joe I was
really I was really into yours but then
it seemed like there wasn't quite enough
there there they just had a lot more
beef in their pitches so I had to came
down to cucumber and Edie for me on this
one and cucumbers opening salvo was just
a delight it was point by point I'm like
and you better bring something to the
table I thought I did and man I really
he won me over with his Pacific Rim
meets Logan so
I'm going I'm going
ed Grier with the rock and Optimus Prime
these two old Cowboys going for one last
ride Dan oh I I gotta side with Joe
Ed's pitch made the last Transformers
movie sound like The Importance of Being
Earnest and too much for me too much
very just kinda just felt like the key
thing and the kitchen sink and four
other kitchen sinks so it was between
cucumber and Joe for me and I agree
cucumber had a fantastic opening but I
think that Joe won me over with the
thematics with the with exploring the
deeper themes of the franchise and and
Keuka I liked initially cucumbers pitch
but I think it got a little also along
with Ed's a little convoluted with the
extra Transformers that you're shooting
out and different Timmy Joseph's the
most concise it felt a little different
so I I'm siding with Joe right onto one
Fred one for Joe Danielle did the
internet say anything that will help us
out here nope 42% for cucumber 36% for
Joe's and then 20% for Ed's which we
found to me and as much as I enjoyed all
of those pitches and I did every one of
them was clear but this isn't ideas
round so it is kind of also like
personally which movie do I want to see
the most and if you guys know anything
about me I want to watch the robot
breakdance movie so I have to go with
cucumber boom cucumber clean sweep in
the first three round
that means cucumber
well cucumber you just punched your
ticket at speed round and one of these
gentlemen is going to the Big Dance
put in some March Madness terminology
okay so buddy not a proud moment you're
got a tie break to break the 0-0 tie
also not a proud moment a god damn
puppet is mopping the floor friend sir
sorry I apologize to all felt the
friends that was very problematic is
that you're up in the powered alright
cucumber you've uh you've made mincemeat
of them you've slice and dice them we'll
see who will move on to face change
right up our butts here is our
tiebreaker and the tiebreaker
yeah used you as puppets tiebreaker
works thusly I'll ask the question shout
out your answer and then you'll the
first person I hear will get twenty
seconds to elaborate and then the other
person will get twenty seconds and then
ten second rebuttals in the same order
here it is the matrix it was revealed
almost starred Sandra Bullock as neo who
would be the best choice besides Keanu
Reeves to take on that role like at the
time or just anybody either way either
way who would be the best choice to take
on the role of neo I'm going Janelle
Monae got Janelle Monae I'm the original
casting choice of Will Smith okay I've
got Janelle Monae we got some Big Willie
style uh Joe we heard you first 20
seconds begin when you speak now I think
would Monet you have a cool x-factor
because she's never led an action
franchise like this before so there's
sort of a WoW interest of who is this
new leading lady I think she fits into
the outsider aspect of Neos world both
before and after he enters into the
Machine as the Lyubov as the lonely
hacker and as this like bizarre Savior
that's very strange like we all wear
leather and vinyl world I can see her
fighting side by side with Trinity
we've seen in certain movies like I am
Legend which has its fans amongst myself
that he is quite a bit a better actor
than we we perceive in certain men and
blacks and independence days and things
this nature and I think he could be able
to get to the place at least the place
that can oh god in regards to being our
audience conduit our tabula rasa as you
will as we get all this technological
information we've also seen Will Smith
flatline and stuff like after earth so
that like dour sort of moodiness that
that neo necessarily needs he couldn't
necessarily pull off but I see gentleman
II having chemistry with this whole cast
a love interest of Trinity you can
attack my star because my star has made
so many more movies and my star as an
actual action star who would be put in a
movie of this type he was almost cashed
for the role he has quite charismatic
enough to carry this he can he's act
he's a physically fit for the kind of
time alright you know what I just heard
more interesting points about Janelle
Monae and got me more fascinated about
the role rather than a little bit of a
rehash of what we know of Will Smith I
got to go Joe
Danielle me first half cool no it's fine
um you know I have to as much as I again
these were both fantastic arguments I
thought that Edie had a lot of really
interesting things to say but for the
same reasons I've got to go with Joe as
well
Joe star uh welcome you just punched
your ticket to the speed around I
punched my ticket back into ed and I
doing more couples therapy and good
stuff I look forward to seeing what
you're gonna draw during this that's
become an annual tradition rare
tradition because you're usually
fighting it on the speed round and well
played good sir and let us venture into
the speed round works the same as the
way the tiebreak just worked alright
cucumber you're ready for this why Joe
star do it alright question and that did
not count for a point so it is still and
this is we enter the speed round
at game point cucumber Wow Joe you need
this to keep her going let's get her
done you're good all right question
question numero uno of the speed around
producer Guillermo del Toro's scary
stories to tell in the dark has a new
trailer what horror movie would most
deeply traumatize a ten-year-old child
what horror movie would most deeply
traumatized a ten-year-old child
poltergeist
we got poltergeist
the visit the visit
that's the shyamalan yeah yeah sir yeah
yeah
mmm I trauma on to visit and I assume
you're talking about the the poltergeist
from the eighties nothing yes yes yes
okay we heard you first cucumber 20
seconds begin when you speak poltergeist
hits you with the tangible and the
intangible the the profession you know
it sucks little girl into the TV there's
there's bodies that pop out of the floor
furniture rearranges the little doll
that should seem safe to these young
children are not any longer it's it's
just terrifying all around Joestar I
think a lot of the elements in
poltergeist will have already scared a
kid by the time they're 10 clowns dead
trees blew the visit a grandparent
should be safe
a visit to a grandparents place that
that those are safety with those are
intimately connected people to your life
into your family and throwing and
casting a shadow of a doubt on that I
think can be deeply unsettling for a kid
10 second rebuttal cuke all people are
scary by definition kids already freaked
out by little people so it's not a big
deal but poltergeist you have actual
ghosts and hauntings and terrifying
stuff that's actually happening damn I
might have said something against felted
friends were you just a gist right there
just heart
I think the fun of some of the elements
of poltergeist is that a lot of kids
just even like that kind of stuff they
like being scared by things that jump
out at you but again there's like a
deeply psychologically scarring thing
that might not even scare them right in
that instant but like later on time
alright Dan Merle your thoughts on this
first question of the speed round very
difficult there were old people that
scared me when I was younger so old
people that didn't scare me so it's very
close but I'm gonna have to go Joe
alright Danielle yeah these both great
arguments I really you know the
difference between the tangible and
intangible taking things like dolls and
making them scary what's great I do
think that Joe kind of hit it out when
he mentioned you know there's a
difference between jump scares which
kids do like kids play that Friday night
at Freddy's game or whatever and
something that's deeply psychologically
scarring so I'm gonna have to go
gentlemen all right Joe you're on the
board three one cucumber three one still
game points here we go and we learned
that cucumber hates the elderly it's
okay to say that though because we do
not have any elderly viewers maybe we do
if you are old and watching Joe I've
seen I've seen the stats out it's
literally 0.9 percent of our honey one
of them is my mom my mom thank you okay
question number two it is still game
point cucumber this is fun who would
have a better chance against Godzilla
John wick or Ethan Hunt John wick
Ethan Hunt okay we got wick we got hunt
cucumber spoke first with John wick 20
seconds between speak now literally
unstoppable and far more lethal than
Ethan Hunt is John wick is super super
mad if Godzilla squishes that little
puppy he's doomed that's the end of them
no more no more Godzilla you would just
the bullets it's like throw knives into
his eyeballs and just keep on going
Rizzoli and awesome
I would watch spooky Joe I think John
wick is a very effective blunt object
and against other people sure he's
unstoppable but Godzilla isn't a person
he's a problem and Ethan Hunt is a
problem solver that's his whole thing
he's not just an action guy he solves
puzzles he thinks he uses logic to apply
to the things that he's got to overcome
and Godzilla in all of his movies it's a
problem to be solved and be overcome and
I think Ethan Hunt is the guy to do it
whereas gun foo isn't necessarily going
to stop Godzilla I think in this case
it's tool against tool Godzilla is a
force of nature so is John wick Ethan
Hunt was it who's gonna pull off his
face me all-time in terms of tool versus
tool scissor vote scissor and rock paper
scissor just leads in a tie are you
losing but if you will apply the
appropriate tool to solve Godzilla which
is Ethan Hunt then I think you have your
solution I think Ethan Hunt is the guy
that could beat them all right you know
what I I think I gotta go I gotta go Joe
on this just because he's solving the
problems Ethan Hunt deals with things
bigger than than just the person versus
person the the hand-to-hand combat kind
of action so yeah I got a go Joe with
Ethan Hunt dan cucumber brings up a good
point which is that a lot of Ethan hunts
effectiveness relies on the masks that
would be against God's own
the bell of the bell is rung the one you
the point however you didn't and so I
think that in a close fight cucumber had
a great counter so I got to go with
cucumber alright one one Danielle okay
yeah these again both of them had really
really solid points as funny and truly
funny is of thinking of Ethan Hunt
taking off the mask Joe really he was
able to parry I think every Joe I don't
know knives he was important to come
back with things to everything that
cucumber brought up
Godzilla isn't a person he's a problem
was great applying the appropriate tool
for the appropriate job was an amazing
closure I'm gonna go with Joe all right
Joe you creep ever closer it's three two
three two cucumber also this movie
fights has rendered gun foo and Keaton
foo which I really enjoy okay question
number three Tom Hanks will play Colonel
Tom Parker in Baz Luhrmann's new Elvis
biopic what musician would inspire the
lamest Hollywood biopic what musician
would inspire the lamest Hollywood
biopic Donny Osmond Donny Osmond Rivers
Cuomo okay we have the Osmond brother
and we have the frontman of Weezer we
heard Donny first 20 seconds ago when
you go now when you speak now I present
you a life with no struggle success from
youth success into adulthood success
into a middle-aged how entertaining he's
got a nice smile
that's about it Donny Osmond oh man 20
seconds
Rivers Cuomo Osmonds always been
successful but there's a struggle to
stay that successful with Osman you've
got Vegas you got magic you got weird
drugs and party stuff there you've got
you've got Disney you got doing Mulan
you got a lot of things with Osman
Rivers Cuomo was just a guy who's made
some decent music and he's kind of
coasted on it for a long time there's
nothing really special about him he
recently covered Toto's Africa it sounds
just the same as Otis Africa because
he's vanilla and boring vanilla and
boring is Donny Osmond's middle name
there's nothing to him I think there's
at least an interesting story to a
lifelong of success like Osmond from kid
to adult I think that's cool VORs Rivers
Cuomo is just a very sort of bland
middle-of-the-road
supermarket song sort of artist he's
never really had any conflict all right
Danielle Radford what do you got um you
know in the Battle of the boring that
could only be one true winner and for me
I think that a cucumber I never had it
full of Donny Osmond just that opening
line of a life with no struggles a movie
about someone who has been nothing but
successful be that sounds super boring
so I'm gonna go with the cucumber yeah
you know what for those same reasons I
gotta go cucumber as cucumber you just
one movie fights well played well played
sorry to call you a puppet earlier my
bad please tell us where we can find you
shout some stuff out and congrats on on
an epic movie fights victory you can
find us at perception studio on Twitch
no space and we'll also be a WonderCon
we're gonna be on a panel on Sunday so
if you're in town come say hi very cool
cucumber always great to have you thank
you for bringing it today uh ed gree are
always awesome to have you can you show
us what you drew in that speed round is
a bunch of stuff but mostly that this
face is okay I guess yeah that's a
pretty good face
and tell us where we can find you buddy
you can find me on instagram at Edgar
destroys for art that took me more than
ten dejected minutes to do also you can
Edgar destroys and no I gotta play the
part okay I can't say that I was
relieved destroys on Twitter and
Instagram and check out my podcast nerd
goat podcast it's gaining traction we're
five-star rated podcast we have a
patreon it's it's deep dive on people's
favorite fictional characters and I
think I'm a bit better at interviewing
people than battling so you've you've
certainly left a body count here you're
pretty good at battling as well and
always great to have you brother Joe
starfuries come back there in the speed
round and you know always a pleasure to
have you about halfway up the mountain I
feel good about it right on I'm still
won but you know any anything you want
to shout out anything uh
nah man I love working with with these
two if you it seriously takes some time
whether you're a tabletop fan whether
you've ever looked at a D&D book go
check out perception check Studios on
Twitch it's so so fun to watch it's it's
a great time please check those guys out
you know if you want to support cool
independent stuff like the stuff that
you guys are doing with and I mean it's
complete respect on duct tape strings in
a dream you know is is awesome seriously
and you guys should go check it out I
hate this tool hated him for 10 years
and I'm so stoked that you're here on a
regular basis man I really really
I love doing the stuff with you how
you're fine the Dan's are great Billy
Ryan's love you guys thank you guys for
caring about her stupid thing Thank You
Joestar Dan cam dan Moreau any box
office predictions so what's Dumbo gonna
clock in at good money watchin how I
don't know reviews have been kind of
right down the middle
mm-hmm I don't know I'm not doing
charting next week so you'll have to
just watch somewhere else to find out
yeah I don't know find out about his big
dummy or somewhere else
if I were going to take a guess I have a
suspicion that it might underperform a
little bit see who knows interesting I
would like to give a shout-out to you
job on a technical theater department
high school the crew in the lock rail
everyone back in the booth the lights
Jeff come in keep crushing it I got a
calendar with all of our show dates
right now ramaa Club represent oh we
were no club pal we took it very
seriously
nicely done man micro aggressions
against felted friends against the drama
societies Daniel Radford thank you for
being awesome and delightful as peruse
oh thank you very much thanks everyone
you can find me on twitter at daniel
Radford you can find me to instagram at
daniel underscore Bradford
and just to say to my old high school
mount to Houma you can suck it
[Applause]
yeah if anybody's watching from northern
highlands Regional High School what up
find me at how Rudnick on Twitter and
Instagram we are going to be doing a big
old honest trailer and movie fights
panel at WonderCon this Friday night 7
p.m. so if you are anywhere in the
Anaheim region come to WonderCon and
hang out with the screen junkies and
watch the movie fights and the honest
trailers and the whatnot if and you
don't have to be Kevin Costner or Ken
Burns to be excited about the big first
day of baseball season off you're
enjoying that more power to you and
thanks again for watching al nationhood
who Billy biz jte cucumber Congrats
thank you alright bye
[Music]
you